salut aujourd'hui pour le mental blog
exceptionnellement je suis fait une mais
par monsieur charles hudon c'est lui qui
est derrière la caméra mais tu ne le
vois pas aussi avec camille avec un car
je suis ravi qu'on puisse faire cette
vidéo ensemble s'est longtemps parce que
les coûts de camille et elle avait comme
dans leur dos et qui avait été filmée
par charlie dont la boucle est bouclée
il n'y a pas de coïncidence ici je
voulais te laisser un cadeau aujourd'hui
je vois comme on voit comme la boucle
est bouclée tu va repartir avec un
cadeau c'est un carré magique un carré
magique c'est un carré de 4 cas sur
quatre cases à l'intérieur duquel il ya
des nombres des chiffes pas forcément
consécutifs et tous différents et le but
du jeu c'est que la somme de chaque
ligne et de chaque colonne sont
identiques à un seul et même résultat et
là vous vous dites on va bien se marrer
dans le mental blog j'ai juste besoin
qu'ils me disent quelque chose dessus
34e ce monstre ou c'est pas possible
avec au dessus de 34 75 75 75
ok ça marche on va lui dire 444 pour
déconner c'est parti
oui je parle pas beaucoup de vent ce
moment là et là je parle et c'est une
très mauvaise idée
56 ça c'est un sas et 1,4 on dirait pas
trop hein alors y'a que des noms vont
pas forcément con sic qui fait tous
différents et ce qui est intéressant
c'est le cadeau que je te laisserais
camille et c'est que la première ligne
on a évité on salue fait 19 et 55 74 et
1 64 58 et 2 56 56 et 7,63 et de 75 3 et
5 ans de 69 69 6 75 10 et 5 15 et 4,19
de 56 75 mais si tu regarde aussi vous
vous mettez pause chez vous sur la
colonne 8,54 du 3 bis a fait 75 ici on a
75 75
les 75 et en même temps parce que quand
même ça ça va faire presque un an de
boltzmann qu'on se connaît j'ai mis la
première diagonale ici 56 et nappé de
limite ça fait bien 75 10 et 57 et
s'était ainsi fait 75
les quatre ici francs 64 points à 1 175
les battures un regard des 4 la faune 75
yards à 75 75 75 75 et 74 ans m ça doit
être bluffant mais j'ai pas retrouve à
six places et e.on et sac à dos le signe
pas ça voudrait trop d'argent qui
pourrait te faire agresser
jamie est ce que je dis aux gens de
tissus surtout permis suivez camille sur
twitter avec et de ses cabinets avec un
casque camille alors fuckly camille avec
un câble est ami avec km2 elle peut avec
avait aussi un cas voilà en fait je vous
mets le lien dans le descriptif et sera
beaucoup plus simple
merci camille donc rendez vous demain à
17 heures pour le prochain mentale blog
chat